now do you remember actually the sisters
is helpful here we said horizontal
stretch or squeeze depending on which
one you're doing here we said medical
now excuse me if you've got a horizontal
and a vertical stretch that means you
can have a horizontal or a vertical
other thin right so this is why I've got
five on here you'll see when I I need
more space on the board so if you'd like
me to add a number where would you like
me to add it to the end okay so oh yeah
if I say for example do y equals sine X
and I'm going to add something on the
end now what is this the play let's draw
a graph showing now I'm going to first
think about this in terms of range range
what's the range of okay what's the
range of the original sine function the
original sine function goes between
negative 1 and 1
that's the lowest singer and that's the
highest it can go but now what you're
doing is you're adding 1 to everything
right so see this spot where I used to
be 0
where you're going to add 1 to that so
it's going to become 1
you see this spot over here where I used
to be one well you're going to add 1 to
that so you're not gonna be at 1 anymore
you're going to be at 2 and you can keep
going doing this all the way I've
something at this last point down here I
used to be at negative 1 but I'm a 1 to
that so therefore I'm going to be at 0
so the lowest the graph can go now is
not negative 1 it's 0 and the highest
type ego is not one anymore
it's two so instead of away from
negative 1 to 1
I've moved the whole big upwards between
0 & 2
the reason why I put that up first is
I draw my axes properly I'm not gonna
draw it right through the middle I'm
actually gonna draw it like this because
my new range is 0-2 okay what do you
think does it make sense to you what
we've done we're just taking them to
steam and we've actually moved it up one
whole unit vertically right so what
would you call this I would call this a
vertical shift and that's why I point
yeah
you can stretch horizontally or
vertically and then you can ship it
horizontally or vertically we just need
the vertical right one right now
so I'm gonna set it very cool so you can
see right in the middle here this spot
which is 180 degrees is now lifted off
the axis it's an intercept anymore okay
it's still kind of the same graph but
it's been threaded a long time different
middle line
okay you see I'm not on the axis but
that middle line unless you know
remember I said it made sense that this
is a horizontal change because look
where I'm putting numbers I'm putting
the two and the half I'm putting them on
at achieving them to the X right and
then I said over here even though we
don't usually write it like that the two
or the half is attached to the one which
is why it makes sense that things are
changing up and down how about give this
guy it's not written in the most helpful
way to help you see what's going on if
it's vertical where is the change really
happening it's really happening to the Y
not the X right
which is why why the sign X is kind of
happily on his own there right
this one really should be written like
this
okay you don't have to write it like
that they're exactly the same thing okay
but I think it's more helpful because it
shows you what is going on it shows you
that this number is interacting with
this okay but we do a little bit that
there's a minus sign there but you're
moving up can anyone see me think of
where this has happened in other places
where a minus sign does exactly the
opposite of what you'd expect when
you've been shifting parabolas you've
been doing this for some time now like
if I say asked to do this is we're
putting up in the top right-hand corner
as well if I say ask you to draw y
equals x squared and then I lost you two
next to it draw y equals x minus two
squared okay draw me a little sad antes
up here if you draw a regular y equals x
squared we know what this looks like we
can draw this in our sleep as a parabola
it has its vertex at the origin just
like you're nice and familiar what not
this guy where's he gone he's gone to
the right which you've learned through
practice oh it's the reverse of that
thing right so that minus 2 means that
intercept is plus 2 so you are that's
cool I know he's gonna do this right now
this is exactly the same you see that y
-1 there's a vertical shift because
attached to the wire which way is it
going it's going up in the opposite
direction to this side does that make
sense okay now while we're on vertical
shift sine X and cos x are pretty easy
to move around I want to do tan just
quickly before me more because it's a
bit harder if I said to you y equals
let's do 10x minus 1 can we do that well
definitely not to 360
now because this is a vertical change
right 10x regular 10x it has some
vertical asymptotes right if you take a
vertical asymptote which remember goes
from red line in both directions and you
move it up and down because that's what
this is doing moved me up and down how
different is that vertical asymptote
look when you move it up and down answer
it doesn't look different at all because
room it goes forever up and down so if
you slide it vertically there's no
change okay
so therefore whatever vertical
asymptotes 10 X 10 10x minus 1 will have
the same ones does that make sense
so first let's draw those on because
they're easy to identify if you've got
not three 6180 where did this vertical
asymptotes go again thank you 90 and 270
let's draw those in first
okay you have to think quite carefully
here I am going to do a vertical shift
I'm going to shift in which direction
downwards this is a shift up this is a
shift down so 10x do you know the graph
well enough to know where does it
usually regularly begin when x equals
zero
what's 10 0 10 0 is 0 isn't it you can
check this with your calculator if you
head back down thank you 10 zero is zero
but I'm not gonna start there anymore am
I I'm guys 0 minus 1
yeah so instead of having any dissent
here at the origin I'm actually going to
move down to unit like that let's call
that negative 1 okay now what does
panics normally do just regular tan X
after he starts off what direction is he
going he goes up doesn't he and he
climbs up toward this acid now before I
put it in do you remember
actually turn back down to your first
time when you drew the tan graph on
Monday morning
I want you to look at it carefully do
you remember I asked all of you to put
on a point for scale or a locking point
right where's the point of sale the one
we chose it's our 45 degrees and the y
coordinate is 1 now think about this
this is the graph you're looking at
right now move down one unit so you know
you're 45 degrees one coordinate it's
not gonna be a 45 degrees common one
anymore
it's gonna be a 45 degrees zero it's
been moved down so that's my x intercept
so you need to put that enmity right I'm
going to posture at 45 degrees I know
it's there cuz halfway between north and
90 and then I'm going to proceed on my
merry way up towards that asymptote just
like drinking the tan X does but I've
been moved downwards
okay are you happy with that so far does
that make sense yeah okay so now what
does the rest of this things like how do
I change the rest of it let me give you
a clue we'll do the easy bits first I've
done sign on the more than one what's
the period of sign again the period of
sign is how long it takes to get one
full copy of sign so it's just an angle
which is 360 degrees okay once you get
there you're back to the stuff but the
period of ten that we notice was
different it's exactly half of that so
it's 180 degrees which means I could
take this shape and if I move it for 180
degrees it should be correct right well
here zero on a roof or 180 degrees -
over here once I get to 180 I'm back to
the start so I'm going to get the same
shape that I graphed over there I'm
gonna graph it over here because it's
the self repeated a full cycle by that
time having this helps me work out where
this and this hard right what's this
intercept going to give you
it used to be 180 it's not what any any
more tourism forty five so I used to be
a 180 I'm guessing now are gonna be at
225 does that make sense okay from there
you can kind of see the rest of the
shape of the tail wrap this guy's gonna
be just heading down towards the acetone
and how do I finish how would you like
me to finish this is tricky what's
happening on that end there
yeah this is just gone down okay it's
going to be coming down a bit but
remember I should meet up with where I
started by the time I go over there
right so usually the regular tank Rack
is at zero backyard but I'm not the
regular tank RAF anymore I have been
moved down one unit okay so the ending
will be here at negative one like that
and then I get the rest of the down copy
okay does that make sense
do you seek out if I were to move this
horizontal axis down 45 degrees knock
down 45 degrees down one unit you get
the familiar tear draft does that make
sense